j'espère que vous allez bien devant
votre téléviseur ou derrière plutôt
parce que c'est moi qui suis devant
bonjour chers chroniqueurs comment
allez-vous
ils vont rien
dedans
ça y est j'ai compris 18h par semaine 18
heures par semaine c'est à peu près
l'espérance de vie qu'on a gagné on la
passe devant les écrans qui est un
progrès considérable pour l'humanité
merci Pascal pour mettre un peu de
positif dans tout ça un peu de gaieté
non mais c'est sympa franchement c'est
sympa
c'est pas bien là dans l'idéologie pure
absolue total
détendu du service public tranquille
vous avez beaucoup changé d'avis ces
dernières années sur les retraites
Marine Le Pen vous étiez pour les 65 ans
avant 17h
pour les 60 ans maintenant c'est plutôt
62 ans vous êtes un peu dur à suivre il
y a des convictions il y a de
l'opportunisme électorale non écoutez
c'est totalement faux et Monsieur Attal
d'ailleurs le sait mais le mensonge est
devenu une manière de gouverner les gens
décédés avant 64 ans devront continuer à
travailler dans l'au-delà c'est faux
bien sûr même si le gouvernement a pensé
à éventuellement les envoyer en télé
locaux de la France insoumise Paul
lafarg écrivait dans le droit à la
paresse qu'il leur fallait pour les
classes ouvrières précisément parce
qu'elle permettait de contraindre les
bourgeois arrêter de surcom au sommet
oui nous en sommes là
[Applaudissements]
nous remplit tous de bonheur notre
Assemblée nationale est en train de se
transformer en ce moment mais c'est pas
nous qu'ils disons c'est eux ce texte il
est arrivé à l'Assemblée vous avez suivi
les débats c'était un grand cirque pour
dire les choses un cirque
on avait bien compris le principe
général de votre question qui n'était ni
finalement sur les étudiants sur les
jeunes mais qui vous permettaient
d'avoir sans doute pour vos réseaux
sociaux les 15 secondes comment on dit
Harol évoqué pour chacun d'entre nous on
joue avec le 3 3 milieu de bourrin
épisme oui
merci dans une manipuler nationale pour
une manifestation effectivement pour une
âgée de Tolbiac transformer l'Assemblée
nationale en camp de gitan et c'est pas
les Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer détective
est-ce que c'est une histoire qui se
termine bien pour vous
il y a beaucoup trop d'arnaques dans ce
bas monde
peut être détective et philosophe
c'est l'une des images du jour des
centaines d'agriculture juchées sur leur
tracteur dans les rues de Paris les
autres affluées pour protester contre
les restrictions de l'usage des
pesticides le 23 janvier le gouvernement
a renoncer à autoriser les
néonicotinoïdes pour la culture de la
betterave sucrière il empêche la
prolifération des pucerons vecteurs de
la jaunisse de la betterave problème
selon ses agriculteurs il n'existe
aujourd'hui pas d'alternatives
on nous laisse finalement à nous
débrouiller et qui c'est qui empathie
toujours c'est le producteur à qui on va
retirer du revenu finalement pour
satisfaire des une idéologie écologique
alors on va se retrouver dans quelques
instants qu'est-ce qu'on fait après
dites-moi dans l'oreillette parce que du
coup je suis un peu perdu
on enchaîne
il faut mettre le micro brush devant le
monsieur sinon on entend rien ah c'est
dommage il avait des choses à dire mais
il avait froid et on est aussi tombé sur
un mec qui n'avait rien à [__] là
bonjour monsieur vous êtes agriculteur
pour ce gars qui a confondu les
toilettes avec le sèchement
ça a soufflé partout je me suis pris
plein la tronche quoi des bons souvenirs
voilà vous l'avez dans la tête pour
toute la soirée et bien dans la série
nos régions du talent les agriculteurs
ce matin non
plus de 500 tracteurs ce matin dans les
rues de Paris une cover de Baby Shark au
klaxon de tracteur il n'y a qu'en France
qu'on pouvait voir ça
[Musique]
et après Michel joyeux anniversaire
y
ministre de
l'Agriculture et mandat
il va pas rester très longtemps il est
nul je vous le dis autant avant on avait
quelqu'un et doit Julien de Normandie
qui était qui avait vraiment
fait nous le modem c'est lui il est nul
marque fenault il tient pas la route il
est en train de chercher un poste pour
se planter aux prochaines élections
européennes il y a le salon de
l'agriculture qui arrive mais oui c'est
la France l'agriculture
vous allez y aller ou pas mais vous
savez est-ce que vous êtes très ruine
vache non bon bah alors taisez-vous
voilà
et face à autant de contestations
olivier est au fond du soft hier lors de
ces questions au gouvernement il a été
piégé par un député du PS son ancien
parti on s'arrête pas là vous êtes
engagés devant nous à ne pas passer en
force sur ce dossier c'est un exploit
qui méritait bien une photo une carte de
France des magnets complète le résultat
de 8 ans de cordon bleu écrit cette
internaute client fidèle d'une marque de
plats préparé qui glisse un département
par PA habituellement c'est une carte à
trous qui orne les réfrigérateurs le
défi a déjà été relevé par d'autres qui
ont fêté dignement cette petite victoire
un petit commentaire tu comptes
t'échapper comme ça
Olivier dussaupe
[Rires]